Assaf Wand, thank you for being on
20 Minute Leaders.
Thanks for having me.
This is so special.
This is the first 20 Minute Leaders out of
I think 120 that I'm doing in person.
Anything that we can stretch it up is good.
Well I have the privilege of being here
in the Hippo offices.
Being in New Hippo.
I'm fully software engineer here.
And I've been waiting for a very long time
to do a video with you.
So, I'm very happy to do it in person.
Assaf, who are you?
Wow.
Every single person that I meet in the valley
in Tel Aviv, wherever,
they know Assaf Wand.
Everybody knows Assaf Wand.
Why is that?
It's from the picture that
I used to have in Ayalon.
Me and Bar Refaeli hug together, I think.
We don't actually have a picture together.
No of course not.
No, but look at this snout, do you think
I just put in any picture.
I think it's a combination of two things.
I think it's a combination of me being
full enough time in this scene.
Plus basing in the belief that
entrepreneurship is in the
creative environment.
And because of that,
you help whenever you can.
And you pass the back forward
and you're always being helpful.
And the question you should ask is
"How can I help you?"
Over a period of time.
How long have you been an entrepreneur?
How long do you consider yourself?
Is it from back from IDC Israel?
From the army? When do you consider
yourself an entrepreneur?
I don’t know.
I never consider myself an entrepreneur.
I just consider myself
I cannot work for anybody.
I'm the worst employee there is.
So, the only other option for me
was to build my own environment.
Right.
I'm just I'm not very good with hierarchy.
I'm not very good in consulting.
I was a mediocre consultant with McKinsey
I'm a lot better entrepreneur.
I think I'm an okay Manager.
Interesting.
I think I'm set up for you know,
I don't like status quo.
Ever since I was a kid
it doesn't matter what.
I can go to the ice cream parlor,
and I'm like in my mind,
that's the dumbest thing ever.
Because they should pick up the money
in here and do the turnover there.
And then they should--
So you're always thinking about
how to transition?
And I'm not good if I,
And I believe that
you should always jump in and change.
And if you're not, then shut the fuck up.
Because you don't have any say.
And because of that,
basically entrepreneur
or what is considered now to be entrepreneur
you can call it self-employed
in a certain time. In between jobs.
Whatever term you wanna call it.
That's what I'm set up.
Interesting. Okay.
So, Hippo. An entrepreneur you know,
a lot of people are going to cybersecurity
into different B2C products, it’s a lot.
I mean most of the things we see on TV,
are B2C and these really fun products.
And you're going to insurance.
A really heavy industry.
A very old industry.
And not something that the average
entrepreneur industry would say,
"Yes, I'm ready to go into insurance."
Yes. What's up with that?
Probably all of the stuff that I believe
in entrepreneurship, plus all of the
corrections from my prior fuck ups,
exactly in that feat.
So, let's break them into different components.
Let's do it.
One, it's a massive fund.
It's a $100 billion.
Just home insurance itself in the US.
So, I'm not even talking global
and stuff like that.
In the US, it's a $100 billion market.
That grows $5 billion dollars a year.
So, it's not this question of
Gartner is saying that by 2027
This feat is gonna be $2.3 billion.
And you have 17 different companies
vying for VC money
to basically go into that field.
It's also a very interesting thing
Because when you're pitching VCs
it's not about,
"Am I gonna be the most dominant?
And kills state farm in all state?"
No. It has a lot of space for
a lot of other players in the market.
Give us 1% of this market.
We build a five, $10 billion company.
Let's go up 30 thousand feet,
We will recon then we'll come back down.
What is insurance?
What is a home buyers’ insurance?
In the US over the past few decades,
what are we seeing?
Because what we do at Hippo here,
is something pretty unique
in the scope of insurance giving.
Yup. So, think about home insurance
the last hundred years.
Channel is solely VR agents.
You're being sold insurance VR agent.
Right.
The average age of an agent now in the US
is 60.
60?
Yes. There's less than half the agent
that used to be 10 years ago.
Wow. So, now there's a bunch of--
When was the last time that you're able to
But more people are buying home.
So, how does that make sense?
Agents don't wanna sell you
home insurance. They wanna shift
to what you said the commercial home.
That where you don't have high frequency
and you sell a lot more cars on the road.
But do you wanna service people
that have car insurance?
Because every 1.7 years you have a claim
when someone nicked your car,
you had an accident,
and then you're calling your agents.
I need a replacement car.
They fix it. They didn't fix it.
There was a depreciation.
There's a point where I said, "F it."
Listen, I just wanna do it.
I prefer to sell you something that
doesn’t have a high frequency.
And I make a lot more money.
So, hence auto insurance
is shifted to be direct.
You're going to [--]
You've buying VR call center via the web.
Our analysis was that there is gonna be
similar lines that are bound to go
to the route of direct.
Home insurance is one.
SMB is two.
And the third one is life insurance.
And we start to analyze all of these things
And we thought home insurance
is something that fits our core skills of
going deep into specific areas,
a lot of data, and this is gonna be tweaks.
So, firstly moving into the direct.
To enable you to purchase
however you want.
You can buy online mobile via
our call center that belongs to us.
Via other insurance company that
sells it. Via independent real agnostic.
You always gonna get the same price.
Second thing, coverage is stuck in the 60s.
So, if you actually have the time
when you're ever gonna do it.
you're gonna open your home insurance
policy, you'll see that you're cover for
stuff like foreclose, $5,000.
Mausoleums and crypts, $6,000.
I don’t know.
China silverware, copperware,
things like that, gold bullions, covered
Stamp collection, $2,000.
Physical bonds that your granddad
gave you for, covered.
But electronics capped at $2,000.
That's you have at the old back.
Now that you have this fancy equipment
it's even more.
But it's more than that.
Home office, not covered.
Bicycle, camping equipments,
tools, ski equipments.
So, basically the things that actually are
happening with the millennial generation
within new home buyers.
Not just millennials.
I'm not a millennial.
And I have a lot more electronics
in my home office, and you know
a lot of other stuff that happens.
There were some other stuff that
when we started the company was also
challenging lifestyle for us.
For instance gay couples,
In state that wouldn’t recognize it
couldn’t be registered as both of them
on the same policy.
Really. Yes, because it's recognized as the
they are married. So, they're not ready.
So, we lived together but only my
half of the closet is covered for lawsuit.
But not your half.
It was just very foreign to us,
to our people if they're alive.
And we thought that this is about
modernizing insurance.
And doing like that.
So, we started the company five years ago.
While the thought was,
We're gonna build--
Or modernizing insurance.
That's the second thing.
We started with like,
We're gonna build progressive or GEICO
for home insurance. Even if you buy.
That's how we started.
Then we realized, the coverages are off.
So, we need to modernize home insurance.
And now, we're at the point which is
it's for the not misbranding kind of thing
because we haven’t massage it enough.
But it's a shift on being a reactive company
to proactive.
Insurance is a reactive experience.
Yeah. But crappy onboarding that they want,
we changed that.
We spend a lot of time.
You're very familiar with that.
To make it seamless.
Prefeed all of the data for you.
And then you have a crappy experience
at [--], which we have
a [--],
and were doing everything 24/7.
And we have an MPS of 70 on the claims.
When you have a--
On the claims. On the claims.
In the horrible situation
you have an MPS of 70.
Because we need to be very honest
with our customers and help them there.
And what really drives me now,
is this nine-year time frame,
that Michael is a customer of Hippo,
until you have a claim.
Now think about that time.
A insurance companies don’t even call you
a customer. They call you a policy holder.
Because the customer was the agent.
Not the end customer.
I would say the day that I onboarded Hippo
the number of times that my onboarding
managers told me,
"Michael, we're looking at customers.
Not policy numbers.
Just get that out of your head.
We're customer forward
We're just forward."
Yes. Now we have multiple agents
that sell us. Also, our customer.
It's completely fine.
We need to build them tools,
to basically address them
in the rightful way,
just like we need to focus back
on the customer.
So, think about that.
You bought a policy.
It was a shitty experience. Fine.
You forgot about it.
And then you know upfront,
when you bought a policy.
That after nine years
when you're gonna have a claim,
the first sentence that's gonna come
out of your mouth is,
"I knew this shit's gonna happen."
For nine years,
Ive been seeing guys every month.
And just when it's gonna happen
I knew this is gonna happen.
Like you know when you--
Show me how many products in the world
you're buying it knowing
it's gonna be like that when it's gonna happen.
More than that, it's a bizarre product
to begin with and we can have a
side discussion on that.
It's a product that US customer
don't ever wanna use and Mia is the person
who actually give you the product
don’t want you to ever use.
It's a very awkward kind of border.
Okay. So, now what we decide is
this nine-year time frame
that you were customer,
How can we align interest?
How can we treat our customers differently?
Now, you don't wanna hear
from your insurance company,
me sending you weekly
Like what the hell, just got to block me
on the spam and we haven’t done anything.
So, there needs to be something deep
in alignment.
And insurance now is a reactive forces.
You're paying every year on the renewal.
Then after nine years you have a claim.
And now the insurance companies,
that's the time to deliver on that.
It's usually it doesn’t work with.
So we thought about that.
What's the best experience in the world
for a claim?
Is that you had a claim,
and five seconds later someone’s step in
you had a damage in your roof.
There was a leak in the roof.
And its $20 thousand.
You need to replace your roof.
And five seconds later, someone came.
Michael, here’s your $20 thousand check.
Which is exactly the sum.
And this is as good as it can be.
But then for three weeks
you're not gonna be at home.
You need to find a contractor
to fix your roof.
You probably lost some of the artifacts
that you have in the stuff.
All of your favorite clothes.
Your favorite sofa. And it's a mess.
And this is as good as it can be.
That someone gave you.
My insurance company was amazing.
I had a damage and they paid everything
on the spot.
That's not a crappy experience.
So, we thought what can be better than that?
And we thought that the best experience
is if we avoid a claim from happening
in the first place.
Which is good for us an insurance company.
But it's very good for you.
So this is was our shift.
To be proactive insurance company.
That has three components.
One, we basically said,
"Why do we use the data only once?"
If I'm already pre-filling all of the data
aerial imagery to see the condition
of the roof. Permit records and all of that.
Why are doing it only once
for the onboarding?
Shouldn’t we do underwriting
on a on-going basis?
So every time I have an
aerial imagery pulled.
We're running all of our customers
basically homes through that.
And if there is a discoloration on the roof,
on Michael's home,
Someone is gonna call your citizen.
Our datas, you know the home monitoring
your home from time to time.
Our datas also showed that
you had a discoloration on the roof.
I think we should send roof serve.
Anyway, it's gonna be free of charge.
I mean, that's for the modernization
where you're not relying on just them
filling out a 15-minute questionnaire of,
what year was roof build?
No, but you know it's exactly--
You go and you're automatically
you're able to pulling these sources and
it's not just passively pulling them.
You're also actively looking in
developing technologies.
They are able to look at pictures.
Look at aerial maps.
Consulted with different APIs and
then real perform a high analysis.
It is ongoing and let's do an ongoing
to help prevention from happening
in the first place.
I give you an example.
I think 14% of our customers
have something material
changing their house
when it comes to renewed.
And I mean, added a swimming pool.
Turn the garage into a living room.
Do a full redo of the kitchen
and stuff like that.
Not a single one called us.
Now, I don’t blame them.
Because it's not why they--
Now, when we're calling our sales,
Now Michael, we saw that you added
a swimming pool. And by the way,
I think we should increase your liability
insurance because there’s a chance that
that the kid's neighbor is gonna jump
into the pool when you're away.
And it's risky.
I think we should increase it.
It's gonna cost you an extra two dollars
per day.
And 99.9% of them say,
"Oh, thank you so much.
I really really forgot about that."
Now, sometimes it’s the other way around.
Sometimes we saw that the permits
would show that you replace the roof.
And you're entitled to a 5% discount.
It's not about maximizing and upselling
It's about making sure
That this contract that we have
of the insurance company and the insured
is that we'll gonna be the safety net.
And instead of the safety net,
we're smaller and smaller and
have gaping holes.
We're constantly making sure that
it's the right kind of safety net
to catch you if God forbids something happen.
And this is what [--]
So, one is using the data to do
ongoing on the lighting.
Second thing is we give packages,
IOT device. We actually, in this home
you can probably bring from
the other side of the table. Yes.
Actually, this is one of the most
one of the things that excite me most
about what we're doing here. It's this.
We have several formats.
This is every customer of Hippo is getting.
That. Let's open that.
This is your kangaroo?
This is the kangaroo 1.
Wow. It is so cool.
It has a bunch of stuff.
It has a motion sensor.
Smoke detector.
Fire Alarm.
What happens when the person gets it
The first they smile and then
They just plug it in.
They install it. What happens then?
So A, they get a discount.
They get a smart on discount.
For the products.
B, these are self-monitored kits.
This is not Hippo's monitoring
them with these things.
We have two smart-on kind of strategy.
We have something which is the basic one
which is self-monitor. Which is this one.
And then we have official monitoring.
Where you're also paying $15 to $20
a month and you get a full monitoring
or you know.
And then it doesn’t come to us,
It comes to the police and stuff like that.
But we only get if it’s on or off.
But it's self-monitors.
It's not living Big Brother
and monitoring that and copy.
It's not about that.
It's about alerting you that you have
a water leak in your basement.
Now, I'm gonna go and check it out.
As oppose to the water leaking
for three days
and then I'm coming to the basement
and then it's completely full.
It's about these things.
So, one is using the data ongoing.
Second one is smart home.
And every customer is basically
unless they opt out, get that.
Are people open to doing that?
To look in the--
We have I think 75% to 80%
installation rate.
So, which is crazy. That's insane.
Which is crazy because 10%, 12%
are opting out.
So, 8% are like you know,
[--]
When I see a win-win situation,
you're sending them these devices that
Hippo is sponsoring. Then you tell them,
"Listen, we're not gonna make money
off of this. Let's form a win-win.
You're gonna plug this and you get
a discount on your quote.
And you're not gonna lose your house.
You're not gonna lose your belongings.
None of us want that.
You don’t wanna lose your belongings.
We don’t wanna file a claim.
So let’s come up with a win win situation.
Or we avoid it in the first place.
It's on us. And you get to--
That was exactly the strategy of design.
That is so cool.
And is that proving itself? Yes.
So, now you have this thing in over
dozens and thousands of homes.
Proving itself? We need more time
to have statistically significant component.
It's a venture capital, you need at least
nine years to show a returns.
It does statistically significant
we know that for me,
everything in insurance
needs to make a claim.
So, for me to say that it reduced by 4%
I need you up over a certain [--]
An AAB to ASN.
But it's definition.
But intuitively as CO because now,
because you have to know.
I get a lot of personal emails.
I get people who are like
Thank you so much for this.
We had a leak in this.
And you stopped it.
Or we have a problem you know,
We walk suddenly in
the middle of the night.
Because there was a fire alarm.
And then we realize there was a fire.
And it was in another room.
And stuff like that.
So, even sporadically,
Even if I have a hundred water claims.
And I stopped one in a hundred.
It's better than not having it.
Plus the sense of trust and stuff like that.
The last thing which is also
interesting for that,
I think it helped build a brand.
So, the thing is this.
If you wanna build a brand, in general.
You need to bring consistent benefit
to a customer.
Insurance companies when I ask you,
"oh, you're auto insure with I don’t know
all state farm, maybe farm mills.
It's all sounds different.
Because nobody use them.
Nobody's in touch point with them.
[--]
And that's it. And then it stays.
And maybe if you have a claim,
you remember that.
I go on my Gmail and I look up
insurance car and I look nobody else.
And then you learn, and then
Yes. Okay, now I need to auto put.
So, think about that.
That in order for us to build a brand,
we need to bring value to the customer
on one on one basis.
This send you, that the door is lock.
the door is unlock.
there was a water leak.
there's not a water leak.
You build an affinity and you pulling it,
that's a good positive kind of thing.
Which is very beneficial.
What's a hippopotamus?
Right outside of this room
we have a huge hippopotamus
staring at us.
Yes. There are two answers.
So the answer I usually give--
I want the real one.
The answer I usually give,
the real one is not, it's sexy adult
So I want the not real one.
Usually, the answer that I'm giving is that
everything with a word mutual, and state,
and farm was taken,
So we have to come up with
something different.
But the real answer is,
so, in the world of branch today
there's no more branch.
Try and fine a name for a company
that you got the domain,
you get the Twitter handled.
and you get the Facebook thing.
You don't have 15 typos
that ends with CO
It's just not something that happens.
So, you're trying to find--
[--]
Let's look at flowers.
Let's look at great gods.
Let's look at places.
Let's look at monuments.
Let's look and you're realizing
really really fast there's no more names.
So, then at the end of the day,
you find something that you know,
you don’t really get the domain,
but the domain is somewhat available.
Your kind of making something and said
"You know what?"
And it's not associated. You go for it.
And in our case, it was Hippo.
Where if you would have asked me,
five years ago, I would have told you,
"There's probably 80% chance
we're gonna change."
It's a place holder.
That was like, let's say we like it
But it's probably gonna pop up
as a problem or something like that.
And we would probably need to do
a re-do of the brand and stuff like that.
And with time, we actually like it
more and more --
It's awesome.
Now, there's also another thing.
I have read too many books on that.
But if I summarized them into
one kind of sentence is,
The earlier the person who can grasp
your brand, the better the brand is.
And the less it associated.
So, apple has no association with
electronics and what it is
But it really worked in grasp the name.
Freaking awesome.
So, you're trying to find something,
Google. Similar, yeah.
But Google is probably an eight-year-old
can grasp. Not a three-year-old.
Then the name Google?
It's not trivial. It's not a concept.
Yeah, its Google.
There is something behind it.
But it used to be a time that progressive.
So, you're trying to find something.
And not that everybody likes that
insurance company so you try to find
something not associated with insurance.
Which is memorable.
It's kind of like you know,
there is the elevator kind of test
on telling a story.
This is, it's an elevator test on
remembering the brand
when someone leaves the elevator.
Not, what's the name of the company?
What's the chances of me telling,
"Listen, we're an insurance company
called Hippo." Just that.
And then three days later,
What was the name? Yes, Hippo.
There's a way higher likely
of the brain memory.
And that was basically
the thought behind it.
Of course we have Hippo stands for
Home Insurance Policy blah blah..
Assaf, I can't believe we already
have to go in a minute.
But I have to get your point of view.
You're in a hyper growth state.
The company is doing very very well.
Already unicorn.
Lots and lots of unemployed.
How many employees are we now
in the company?
270.
270 employees.
Did you think when you sold your
last business that you're gonna be
running five years later?
Of course not. Are you kidding me?
270 employees.
Assaf, you wake up. You have to leave
270 people and it's growing.
So, every week I'm getting new emails.
Welcome blah blah blah.
How do you approach this state of mind?
Have you done this before?
Experiencing this growth?
No. Not ever.
But that's the reason why
we're not selling.
And we're excited to come every day.
It's the growth mindset.
And I personally learn
And the rest of the team.
is learning by evolving
and moving to the next step.
Everyday it's a new day.
It's a new learning.
It's a different company.
I always ask myself,
"Am I the right person to lead the company?"
"Am I the best CEO for the company?"
"Can someone else be better?"
"What do I need to personally learn
to be better?"
Or if I have gaps,
"Who should I break into?"
Do you feel the same intimacy
with the brand and with this desk
and this walls as the days go by
and you disassociate more and more
with the everyday things?
Because you must be different.
Probably the hardest thing for me
on my growth journey,
was to let go of stuff.
I used to know every freakin thing.
Every new office. Every contract.
Everything. And there's a certain point
That you can’t because the entire management
basically experience is about leverage.
Finding someone else than can
level at you. And what you're doing.
And the second thing,
you find people that are way
stronger than you in what they are doing.
You know, Fannie is way better
technologist than what I am.
And in order to attract the right talent,
you need to let go and let them run
their own stuff and not intervene.
And trust them to brief me on the stuff
that I need to be brief.
So, on one side, I'm not on the minutiae
on the other stuff, I'm exposed to a lot
broader kind of things.
Which is so fine and
and really really interested.
That's part of the evolution and the growth.
And I'm constantly, what's the next steps?
How can I evolve?
The day that I feel that I have grown
enough to accommodate the business,
Or that I've hit my mark
That would be a different discussion.
Do you feel that you'll be able to have
the discussion with yourself?
Yeah. I have no egos when it comes
to the company on these things.
Even though it's your baby
and you grow it from day one?
It's not that since I was for reward
I wanted to be a CEO of
a private insurance company.
Or something like that.
That's not the driving force for me.
It's about education, growth,
dream good, making an impact,
learning every day.
Because I think entrepreneurship is shit,
is hard, is difficult.
But there are several things that
you can control.
You can control the domain
that you're working in.
And what you're working on.
The people that you worked with.
And the culture.
And this is the biggest thing.
And as long as you're working
on something that is interesting and
exciting, people that you like,
And I can see the influence of the culture
And I like the culture of the company.
That's probably I'm gonna keep on doing.
I love it. Assaf, three words that
best describe you. How would you
describe yourself in three words?
This is something that I ask
every person on the show.
And it's now fascinating
to see it come together.
So, it's not bored.
So, Independent thinker.
I believe in strong opinions loosely held.
Strong opinions loosely held.
I think that when you come into a
discussion, you should have an opinion.
That you should defend it.
And you should be thoughtful.
But you should be open.
That if someone comes up with data,
and stuff like that. That you're, okay
I can see and you loosely held on opinion.
So the second part is just as important
as the first one? Yes.
Which is part of the other stuff is
we have obligation to descend.
and all of that other stuff is part of the culture.
And then, I think that being immense,
and honest and good friend,
and all of that
is something that is really really important.
For the company. For the culture.
And for me personally.
I love it. Assaf, thank you very very much.
No, I can be happier
than having you on board.
This is fantastic
Bring us a lot more Michaels.
This is fantastic.
And I have to say that walking in here
the culture, it precedes itself.
And yeah, the business is great.
And technologies fantastic.
And I love the people around me.
The culture and the feeling that
of what you've built here
over the 270 employees.
And I can’t wait to see it grow.
And continue to grow.
And it's great to be part of the journey.
Thanks very much.
Thanks so much for that.
Thanks Michael.